where's the dog at  all right  he was all with a lot of saliva yeah  like he wasn't able to breathe you come  to on this sir  are you the owner of this vehicle  the mercedes yes all right  turn around put your hands behind your  back  almost together palms together  don't on don't interlock your fingers  palms together  you have a husky inside the vehicle  any weapons on you sir  any id on you  mary 23 one in custody  back to my vehicle  [Music]  stand right here don't move  let's have a seat  i'm going to jail on a felony willful  endangerment of an animal  you realize how hot it is outside  you know the vehicle off windows up and  you have tape around your dog's mouth  you